MARTIN OMANDER: Hi.
Welcome to "Root Access," the
show on GDL about startups.
My name is Martin Omander,
and I work for
Google Developer Relations.
And today I'm joined by none
other than Don Dodge, fellow
Googler, longtime investor
and startup advocate.
Today we'll deal with some
viewer questions, Don.
And, by the way, thank you all
for your comments on YouTube.
Keep them coming.
We love the feedback.
Don, we recently ran an episode
about how to get
funding and launch your
startup where we
talked about ownership.
And Jacob Williams made a
comment on that YouTube video
saying that the preferred stock
split is to give one
third to each of the two
co-founders, and then another
third to investors.
And that way, no one
can dictate to the
others or make a coup.
Is that how it's usually done?
What are you actually
seeing out there?
What do investors do?
DON DODGE: Well, I suppose
that's one way to do it.
But if control is the issue,
that's probably
not going to work.
First of all, as founders,
you start
owning 100% of the company.
So as founders, you might have
two founders or three
founders, and you divide up the
founding stock in a way
that makes sense to you.
So maybe one founder gets 40%,
and the other two founders get
30% each for 100%.
So you start that way.
Then, when you bring in
investors, they are going to
say, all right, I'll give you
$250,000 for 20% of the
company, or whatever.
You might get $500,000 for
20% of the company.
You don't know until you start
talking to investors what that
valuation is going to be.
But over time, you get diluted
by taking on additional
investment.
When a VC investor comes in,
they will ask you to set up an
employee stock option pool.
That's typically 15% of the
company, sometimes 10,
sometimes 20, but in that
range, 10 to 20%.
So you set aside 10
to 20% of the
company for future employees.
So that's going to dilute you
down from your initial
position of 30% or
40% down further.
MARTIN OMANDER: And dilute, so
you mean actually new shares
are created.
DON DODGE: Right.
So let's say you start out with
the company, and there's
1,000 shares.
And you give 400 shares to one
founder and 300 shares to
another founder and 300 shares
to the third founder.
So that's the 1,000 shares.
Then you bring in investors,
and you create more shares.
So you sell a part of the
company, and you create more
shares to do that.
Typically, the founders have
founders' stock, and then
there's common stock and
preferred stock.
So founders get founders' stock,
employees get common
stock, investors get
preferred stock.
So you create this new stock.
That creates more shares and
dilutes your percentage
ownership every time you
sell more shares.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
So do investors care about
getting a controlling stake?
DON DODGE: Typical not, no.
Angel investors, they invest
their money, and they care
about the valuation a little
bit, and the team mostly, and
that kind of thing.
So they might put in $100,000
or $200,000.
And they care more about
getting in early at a
reasonable low valuation and
then helping you build a
company up to a level where
you can go to VCs.
Venture capital investors tend
to care more about percentage
ownership and not so much
control, but percentage
ownership, and not for
control reasons.
They care about it for
return on their time.
Because it takes the same amount
of time to make an
investment in a company where
you control 5% of it as it
does to make that same
investment where
you have 30% of it.
So they're going to invest their
time and their money
where they have the most
ownership percentage for the
return on their time, not so
much because they get control
of the company.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
You mentioned on founders'
stock, preferred stock, common
stock, are those just words that
describe stock you give
out at different times, or do
they actually work different
and/or have different
legal implications?
DON DODGE: Yes, they
are very different.
So founders' stock, if you're
a founder, you get founders'
stock, and you own that 100%.
So it doesn't vest over four
years or whatever.
So the two or three founders,
they own 100% of
the company to start.
And their stock is fully
vested and fully owned.
Common stock is typically given
to employees in the form
of employee stock options, which
vest over four years and
has a strike price.
So as employees come in, you
give them common stock in the
form of employee stock
options, and
it vests over time.
Preferred stock is for venture
capital investors.
And it's called preferred
because it has some preferred
provisions in the agreement that
allows them to get their
money out first.
So they have preference
over common stock
or founders' stock.
They get their money out first
in the case of a liquidation
or bad event.
They might also have warrants or
other types of preferences.
So, yes, there are three
different types of stock, and
they're very different
legally.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
Thank you very much, Don, for
making that clear for us.
And thank you all
for watching.
Please leave your comments and
any questions you'd like us to
pick up in future episodes
in the YouTube comments.
We really appreciate
your feedback.
And finally, I am also a
developer, and I love
developing on the Google
Cloud Platform.
And as a special offer, we have
a $2,000 credit that you
as "Root Access" viewers
can access.
Please just follow the
instructions on screen to sign
up for your credit and get
started on the cloud platform.
Thank you very much.
See you next time.